all right we're going to be in though
with the breaking news the fast approach
of hurricane Ian now a category 4 storm
but edging toward category five status
just hours now before making landfall in
the State of Florida high winds and
flooding already being reported in the
southern part of that state and more
than two and a half million people at
this hour are under mandatory evacuation
orders as the possible once in a century
storm barrels toward the Gulf Coast
hurricane Ian has already ripped through
Western Cuba with winds up to 125 miles
an hour the entire country is without
power this morning we've got a team of
Correspondence bracing for the storm in
Florida led by our lead National
correspondent that would be David begno
David is in Tampa which is expecting
extreme rainfall today but David right
now it looks sort of like the Calm
before the storm true
the calm Gale but the rain and the winds
have started the temperature has
actually started to drop so we are in
Hillsboro uh County we're at the
Hillsborough River right at the top of
Tampa Bay and again this area has
already to has started to experience
tropical storm Force conditions
hurricane Ian is still about 60 miles
off the coast of Florida officials say
this is going to affect all Floridians
not just the people on the state's
western coast Key West Florida
experienced storm surge last night that
actually filled streets and homes
Statewide you've got more than 50 000
people who are already without power
this morning storm surge around parts of
southwestern Florida could be as high as
12 feet now in preparation for the worst
many people have followed the evacuation
orders a lot of people left yesterday
others though are hunkering down hoping
sandbags and boards on Windows is going
to help to keep them safe yesterday last
night we had a chance to ride around
with a Hillsborough County Sheriff's
deputy who was surveying an area that
was under mandatory evacuation and I
have to tell you from what we saw most
people are staying behind